In the world of horse racing, the name of
a given horse is considered to be almost as
important as its ability to run.
Thanks, in part, to a large number of rigid
rules put in place by the the various governing
bodies of the sport, picking a name is an
exercise in creativity as much as it is a
simple way to identify a horse.
You see, to race a thoroughbred in near enough
any location on Earth it must have a name
that conforms to strict regulations laid out
by The International Federation of Horseracing
Authorities.
In addition, depending on where in the world
you are, there may be further stipulations
a chosen name must adhere to for the horse
to race in that region.
First though, let’s discuss the rules laid
out by The International Federation of Horseracing
Authorities.
For starters a chosen name can be no longer
than 18 characters long and to make things
just a little more difficult, spaces and punctuation
marks count towards this limit.
For this reason, many owners choose to simple
forgo spaces and punctuation when picking
a name for a horse- our personal favourite
example of which being the horse Eighteencharacters,
a name that is, somewhat amusingly, exactly
18 characters long.
Now, although 18 characters may seem like
plenty, another rule handed down by The International
Federation of Horseracing Authorities that
makes picking a name just a tad more difficult
is that no two horses currently racing can
have the same name.
To avoid confusion between horses, once a
name is registered with the relevant horseracing
authority required, similar sounding names
are also banned.
On top of all this, when a horse retires,
its name cannot be used again for at least
another 20 years with this being extended
to 35 years if the horse goes to stud, again
to avoid confusion and out of respect for
the owner.
This rule is ignored if a given horse wins
a major event, in which case its name is retired
forever.
Exceptions to this rule can be made if a given
horse is competing in another part of the
world, though generally the owner is required
to add the prefix of the horse’s country
of origin to the end of its name to differentiate
it from the other horse.
Reading this you can probably start to understand
why owners choose such eclectic names- but
we’re not done yet.
There are still a lot more rules we need to
discuss.
For example, a chosen name can’t be, to
quote, “in poor taste”, a polite way of
saying it can’t be offensive to a particular
religious, political or ethnic group.
And if you’ve ever tried to say, well, anything,
online, you probably know that almost everything
is offensive to some group out there.
Furthermore, a name cannot be used for advertising
purposes or contain a trademarked term or
something like that.
Understandably, a name also cannot contain
any vulgarity- a rule many owners seem to
take great enjoyment in trying to circumvent,
a few of which we’ll mention in the Bonus
Facts later.
Finally, you cannot name a horse after a living
person without express written permission
from that person.
Moving on to more region-specific rules, in
the United States, for example, The Jockey
Club requires any owner registering a horse
with a name that has “meanings that are
not self-evident” to explain what it means
before it will be approved.
The reasoning being to stop names that may
circumvent any of the previously stated rules
from slipping through the net.
Curiously, The Jockey Club seems to be more
lenient when it comes to allowing names that
are overtly political in nature than other
parts of the world, with horse’s like Obama’s
Promises and Palin Power being approved.
In the UK, on the other hand, Weatherbys (the
administrative arm of the British Horse Racing
Authority) dictates that a name can’t be
more than 7 syllables long- a rule that rarely
comes into play given the 18 character name
limit, so isn’t a rule handed down in other
jurisdictions.
UK horseracing authorities also take special
care to vet names that may have a different
meaning in other cultures- a commonsense rule
given the proximity of Great Britain to the
melting pot of cultures that is Europe.
The difficulty of naming a horse is only compounded
by the fact that in addition to being unique,
a name – as a rule – should be fairly
memorable.
The reason being that nobody is going to bet
on a horse with a lame name, unless it happens
to have a famous owner or heritage.
This is a fact that probably explains why
the Queen is happy to choose fairly boring
names like Pall Mall or Sea Shanty for her
racing horses.
Speaking of heritage, a common trend when
it comes to naming racehorses is to choose
a name that is a subtle hint to the individual
horse’s lineage.
For example, we have the horse Inside Information,
the offspring of a stallion called Private
Account and a mare called Pure Profit.
Another trend when it comes to naming racehorses
is to simply pick a name that sounds funny
or is difficult to pronounce, usually just
to annoy racing commentators.
An example of this is a horse bought by one
of the writers of the film Airplane, David
Zucker named All Pink.
If that doesn’t sound all that funny we
should note that Zucker specifically instructed
the jockey riding All Pink to hug the inside
of the track so the commentator would have
to keep saying the phrase “It’s all pink
on the inside”.
Other examples of naming shenanigans include
horses named DoReMiFaSaLaTiDo, Ha Ha Ha and
simply, ARRRRRR, all of which were named,
partly, to mess with commentators.
To conclude though, the reason racehorses
tend to have such weird names is largely due
to strict regulations handed down by the highest
authorities in horseracing, which necessitate
owners getting, shall we say, creative when
coming up with a unique and memorable name.
In fact, it’s noted that around a third
of all submitted horse names are rejected
outright for breaking one or more rules.
For this reason, many owners submit multiple
names just to ensure one gets accepted as
invariably one or more of them will be breaking
some rule or other.
Despite the best efforts of the relevant authorities
vetting names, countless names some would
consider to be vulgar or offensive have been
unwittingly accepted in the past- examples
include, Date More Minors, Pussy Galore, Bodacious
Tatas, Nutzapper and our personal favourite,
Geespot.
Why?
Because it was the result of a stallion called
Pursuit of Love getting it on with a mare
called My Discovery.
As for names that have been rejected for being
too offensive in the past but we feel compelled
to mention anyway, these include Chit Hot
and Pee Ness.